κριτική αυτό γιαμε έναν είναι κομμμάτι της της δουλειάσμου δεν είναι κάτι που πρέπει να
σας πω ότι το μπερνό παρατήρητα θα ήτα λλάθος να πό ότι το πρνο απαρατήτοόταν
το ακούο προς το θώ να το αξιολογήσω να δω αν αυτό έχει μια βάσι
διότι πρέπει να να ακούσε αυτά που βλέν και την κριτική κριτική για με ένα
πολλές φορες είναι εξαρετικάς σημαντική αλλά δεν είναι κάτι που ανείμε σίγουρι για τα βήματα
που κάνου και ότα κάνω στά δεν είναι κάτι το οποίο θα με επηριάσει τις
πρωτοβουλίες που που είχατε και να ναρκετές αυτές πως επιστέλεε της έπραξε ευρωπιτι εννοείται πως
τις προι βάσεις που έχουν πει θεωίται ότι θα συνεχίσουν ναι βάσεις τις οποίες εσείς
βάλατα νιπιστεύω ότη σίγουρα θα συνεχίσουν και χεαρικά πολύδι ότι για τον επόμενο επίτροπο ηγείας
οι πρόεδρος φοντελάν έχει θασι σα τόχο ότην της συνέχιση της ιλοποίηστης της ευρωπαϊκής ένως
ησηγίας έχουμε οι δι προχωρήσει ενισχείοντας τι ασφάλεια της ευρωπαϊκής ένωσης στα θέματα η γειονομικό
κρίσιων αυτό δεν αλλάζει διότι αλλάξαμε και τους άρους εντολής παραδείγματο χάρι του ευρωπαϊκού οργανισμού
φαρμάκο πριν την πανδιμία για να εγκριθεί ένα νεωφαρμακό στην ευρωπαϊκή ένωση θα λλάμε κάπου
τετρακό σης μέρες και ότα ρώτησα πόσις μέρες θέλουν στεις υνωμένες πολιτείες διότι ακόμε συνέχει
ευγαίνουν νεαφαρμ μου είπαν ο μισός χρόνος αλλάξαμε τις διαδικασίες και τώρα κάπου σε εκατόν
ογδόν τα μέρες θα μπορεί να αγκρίνεται ένα νεοφάρμακο ότε αλλάξαν τα πράγματα έχουμεαλλάξει για
πρώτη φορά έχουμε μια νέερμετα ρίθμηση μια πρόταση για τα φάρμακα για να αντιμετωπίσουμε θέματα